GO THROUGH THIS AGAIN.
I'M GOING TO ADDRESS THAT NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: I WANT TO WELCOME
EVERYONE TO THIS PROGRAM, MAYBE
INCLUDING SOME OF YOU MAYBE THAT
DON'T USUALLY TUNE IN HERE.
THOSE WHO MAYBE NOW REALIZE THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN LIED TO BY OTHER
NETWORKS AND THE NEWS MEDIA ON A
SPECTACULAR LEVEL FOR YEARS AND
YEARS.
YOU KNOW, I LOOK AT SO-CALLED
COMPETITION IN CABLE NEWS, LET'S
START WITH RACHEL MADDOW'S
AUDIENCE.
THEY HAVE BEEN SOLD ONE
CONSPIRACY THEORY NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT, LIE NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT AFTER NIGHT, 22
MONTHS.
SHE HAS PROFITED FROM THESE LIES
TO HER AUDIENCE ON A SPECK
TO HER AUDIENCE ON A SPETACULAR
LEVEL.
SHE AND HER SO-CALLED
COLLEAGUES, SO-CALLED MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS,
THEY SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED
TONIGHT, THEY SHOULD FEEL
HUMILIATED TONIGHT, THEY SHOULD
BE APOLOGIZING TONIGHT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS WELL AS SO
MANY OTHERS IN THE MEDIA.
IT WILL TAKE ME MONTHS, BUT WE
WILL FOLLOW EVERY LEAD AND WE
WILL REMIND YOU WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE HERE.
THE TRUTH HAS BEEN LAID BARE FOR
ALL TO SEE.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION, NO
TRUTH TO THE LIES THAT HAVE BEEN
PEDDLED DAILY.
WE ON THIS PROGRAM HAVE BEEN
RIGHT ALL ALONG BECAUSE UNLIKE
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING THE TRUTH WITH
EVIDENCE TO BACK IT UP.
MANY OF YOU SINCE YESTERDAY HAVE
BEEN WRITING ME AND YOU WANT ME
TO SPIKE THE FOOTBALL TONIGHT.
I AM NOT IN ANY TYPE OF
CELEBRATORY MOOD HERE TONIGHT IN
ANY WAY.
THIS IS A TIME -- YOU SHOULD BE
ANGRY AT WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE.
ALL OF AMERICA.
I AM PISSED OFF AND SO SHOULD
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY BE OVER
WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
JUST BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS -- THIS IS ONLY THE FIRST
CHAPTER.
THIS MUST BE A DAY OF RECKONING
FOR THE MEDIA, FOR THE DEEP
STATE, FOR PEOPLE WHO ABUSE
POWER, AND THEY DID IT SO
BLATANTLY IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF WE DO NOT GET THIS RIGHT, IF
WE DO NOT HOLD THESE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE, I PROMISE YOU WITH
ALL THE LOVE I CAN MUSTER FOR
THIS COUNTRY AND OUR FUTURE FOR
OUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS, WE WILL
LOSE THE GREATEST COUNTRY GOD
HAS EVER GIVEN MAN.
WE WILL LOSE IT.
WE NOW HAVE 675 DAYS, $25 PLUS
MILLION, 2,800 SUBPOENAS, 500
WITNESSES, 500 SEARCH WARRANTS,
DOORS KICKED DOWN, PRE-DAWN
RAIDS, FELONY CONVICTIONS FOR
PROCESS CRIMES, SCREWS TURNED TO
ACCELERATE OR HOPE FOR OR GET
PEOPLE TO LIE TO HURT THE
PRESIDENT.
OTHER LIES, MOUNTING LEGAL BILLS
FOR SO MANY AMERICANS, MANY WHO
ARE NOW FACING BANKRUPTCY LIKE
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN.
A 33-YEAR COMBAT VETERAN.
THAT'S HOW WE REPAY HIM?
AFTER A PRIOR NINE-MONTH
INVESTIGATION THAT FOUND ZERO
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION, AFTER THE
INVESTIGATION FOUND ZERO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THE PRESS NEVER TOLD YOU.
AFTER ANOTHER INVESTIGATION IN
THE HOUSE FOUND ZERO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
LO AND BEHOLD WE LEARN ROBERT
MUELLER HAS FOUND ZERO EVIDENCE
OF TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION ACCORD
OF TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION ACCO D
ACCORDING TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BOB BARR'S SUMMARY
FINDINGS OF THE MUELLER REPORT.
"THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION DID NOT FIND THAT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN OR ANYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH IT CONSPIRED OR
COORDINATED WITH RUSSIA IN ITS
EFFORTS TO INFLUENCE THE 2016
U.S. PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION" AND
LET ME BE CLEAR, A DIRECT QUOTE
FROM THE MUELLER REPORT "THE
INVESTIGATION DID NOT ESTABLISH
THAT MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN CONSPIRED, COORDINATED
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IN
ITS ELECTION INTERFERENCE
ACTIVITIES."
AND THAT'S NOT ALL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALSO BEEN
CLEARED OF THE ISSUE OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, YOU JUST
HEARD FROM JAY.
MUELLER DID NOT DRAW A
CONCLUSION "ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
AS TO WHETHER THE EXAMINED
CONDUCT CONSTITUTED
OBSTRUCTION."
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL DID NOT
CONCLUDE THAT THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED A CRIME, IT DIDN'T
EXONERATE HIM, WHICH THE MEDIA
IS CLINGING ONTO.
READ A LITTLE FURTHER.
AFTER REVIEWING THE MATTER, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO STARTED THIS WHOLE THING,
ROD ROSENSTEIN CONCLUDED "THE
KEY PHRASE THAT THE MEDIA
MISSES, THE EVIDENCE DEVELOPED
DURING THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION IS NOT SUFFICIENT
TO ESTABLISH THAT THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED AN OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE OFFENSE AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT, ACCORDING TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL "OUR
DETERMINATION WAS MADE WITHOUT
REGARD TO AND IS NOT BASED ON
THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS THAT SOUND THE
INDICTMENT OF A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION OF A SITTING
PRESIDENT."
HE CONCLUDED GENERALLY SPEAKING
TO OBTAIN THE CONVICTION, THE
GOVERNMENT WOULD NEED TO PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT THAT A
PERSON ACTING WITH CORRUPT
INTENT ENGAGED IN OBSTRUCTIVE
CONDUCT WITH NEXUS TO THE
PROCEEDING.
ANYONE IN THE MEDIA WHO REFUSES
TO ADMIT THIS TRUTH IS
CONTINUING THE LYING THEY'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN FOR TWO YEARS.
YOU CAN'T OBSTRUCT A CRIME YOU
DIDN'T COMMIT.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, THERE
CANNOT BE ANY OBSTRUCTION.
NO CHARGES WILL BE FILED.
THE MUELLER MEDIA WITCH HUNT IS
FINALLY OVER.
THE BIG QUESTION FOR THIS
COUNTRY TONIGHT, THIS SHOULDN'T
BE ABOUT CONSERVATIVE, LIBERAL,
DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN.
WHERE DO WE AS A COUNTRY GO FROM
HERE?
HOW DO WE PREVENT THIS
UNPRECEDENTED ATTACK ON A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT AND AN EFFORT
TO THEN OVERTURN THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN.
PEOPLE WITH THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF POWER ABUSE
OF POWER ABUING THAT POWER TO
EXONERATE ONE CANDIDATE THAT WE
KNOW SHOULD HAVE BEEN INDICTED,
TO FAVOR THAT CANDIDATE, TO RIG
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, AND
THEN UNDO THE RESULTS THAT THEY
DIDN'T LIKE.
AFTER ALL, YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WE WERE LIED TO OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
MY PROMISE TO THIS COUNTRY FROM
THIS NIGHT FORWARD IS WE WILL
HOLD EVERY LIAR, EVERY
PROPAGANDIST, EVERY CONSPIRACY
THEORIST ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS WILL LIKELY TAKE US MONTHS
AND EVEN LONGER TO UNRAVEL THE
TRUTH.
WE'VE GOT ALL THE TAPE.
WE'VE GOT ALL THE COMMENTS.
IT WILL TAKE TIME.
I MAKE YOU THIS PLEDGE TONIGHT.
EVERY DEEP STATE ACTOR THAT
ABUSED THE POWER THAT YOU, WE
THE PEOPLE GIVE THEM, WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
EVERY SUPER PATRIOT WHO THOUGHT
THEY KNEW BETTER THAN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE WILL HOLD EVERY FAKE NEWS
MEDIA CONSPIRACY THEORIST
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE WILL GET THIS RIGHT.
WE WILL DEMAND WE GET THIS
RIGHT.
WE WILL SHOW YOU WHO CAN NEVER
BE TRUSTED AGAIN.
TONIGHT, WE START WITH THIS
CORRUPT MEDIA MOB IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE NOW KNOW THEY WORK IN UNISON.
THEY ARE ONE ENTITY.
AND FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS,
THERE HAVE BEEN TWO PARALLEL
NARRATIVES IN THIS COUNTRY.
ONE OF COURSE WAS THE TRUTH
WHICH WE HAVE BEEN PROVING NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT AND REPORTING ON
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
AND TOMORROW, ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT DESERVE THE CREDIT WILL BE
HERE WITH ME ABOUT THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION,
SCANDAL PERHAPS IN HISTORY.
THEN THERE WAS THE MEDIA'S PACK
OF LIES ABOUT A GRAND SCHEME
WHERE DONALD TRUMP AND HIS TEAM
WORKED CLOSELY WITH RUSSIA TO
STEAL THE ELECTION.
LITERALLY BREATHLESS REPORTING,
HYSTERIA PUSHED WEEK AFTER WEEK,
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY HOUR OF
EVERY DAY.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE HEADLINES.
THERE'S ACTUALLY LOTS OF
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
WRONG.
THE ATLANTIC, THE COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA IS IN PLAIN SIGHT, WRONG.
HUFFING TON POST, MANAFORT
INDICTMENT REVEALS TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION, A LIE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THOUSANDS
UPON THOUSANDS OF REPORTS IN THE
OPINION AND SO-CALLED HARD NEWS
PAGES ALIKE.
THAT MEANS THE "WASHINGTON
POST," THE "NEW YORK TIMES."
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THEY ACTUALLY
WON PULITZER PRIZES FOR THEIR
LYING COVERAGE OF THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION HOAX.
THAT IS A DISGUSTING DISGRACE
AND A DISHONOR TO EVERY PERSON
THAT DESERVED A REAL PULITZER
PRIZE.
THIS HORRIBLE COVERAGE WAS
AMPLIFIED EVERY SINGLE DAY ON
FAKE NEWS CNN, CONSPIRACY TV
MSNBC.
THIS IS BUT JUST A TINY
SAMPLING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THIS MEETING AND THE
REVELATIONS ABOUT IT ARE A GAME
CHANGER IN THE INVESTIGATION.
THEY PRESENT THE FIRST EVIDENCE
OF ACTUAL COLLUSION.
>> WHAT MR. TRUMP DID YESTERDAY
WAS TO BETRAY THE WOMEN AND MEN
OF THE FBI, THE CIA, NSA AND
OTHERS AND TO BETRAY THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
THAT'S WHY I USE THE TERM THIS
IS NOTHING SHORT OF TREASONOUS.
>> COLLUSION HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED.
>> THE WHOLE NOTION THERE BEING
NO COLLUSION, THIS IS THE
BIGGEST DIVERSION OF THE TRUMP
CROWD.
THERE WAS COLLUSION.
SO THIS PICTURE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SO DESPERATE TO
AVOID, THIS PICTURE OF COLLUSION
BEGINS TO FILL IN.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT'S INTERESTING
HERE.
IT'S BOTH ON ONE HAND VERY
DAMNING BECAUSE IT'S COLLUSION.
>> IT WOULD SEEM THAT COLLUSION
IS OBVIOUS.
A CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY IS
UNKNOWN.
>> THEY WERE THE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN VARIOUS INDIVIDUALS
AFAILUATED WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIAN
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT COLLUSION, I THINK IS QUITE
OBVIOUS AND APPARENT.
>> A POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
THERE.
WE'LL CALL IT HURRICANE
VLADIMIR, IF YOU WILL.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT COLLUSION.
>> Sean: THIS IS ALL A LIE.
AND AT THE HEIGHT OF THIS
HYSTERIA, ESPECIALLY FAKE NEWS
CNN AND CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC, OH,
OF COURSE THEY WERE FEATURING
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY FORMER
STORMY DANIELS ATTORNEY MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
MORE THAN 108 TIMES IN TWO
MONTHS BECAUSE HE HATED DONALD
TRUMP AND AVENATTI WAS
SPECULATING WILDLY AND SPREADING
THESE BASELESS RUMORS AND THEY
ATE IT UP ABOUT TRUMP AND RUSSIA
ON A DAILY, NIGHTLY BASIS.
TODAY, AVENATTI WAS INDICTED IN
TWO SEPARATE CASES SURROUNDING
FRAUD AND EXTORTION.
HE WAS THEIR STAR GUEST ON SHOW
AFTER SHOW AFTER SHOW AND THE
MEDIA WAS DESPERATE FOR THE
FALSE NARRATIVE AND LIE TO BE
ADVANCED.
BRIT HUME CALLED IT THE WORST
JOURNALISTIC DEBACLE OF HIS
LIFETIME.
OVER 50 YEARS IN JOURNALISM.
EVEN FAR LEFT FORMER ROLLING
STONES WRITER QUOTE NOBODY WANTS
TO HEAR THIS THAT NEWS SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR MUELLER IS HEADED
HOME WITHOUT ISSUING NEW CHARGES
IS A DEATH BLOW FOR THE
REPUTATION OF THE AMERICAN NEWS
MEDIA.
JEFF ZUCKER, HEAD OF CNN, ARE
YOU GOING TO APOLOGIZE FOR YOUR
NETWORK'S CONSTANT STREAM OF
LIES AND HYSTERIA.
PHIL GRIFFIN, NBC, ARE YOU GOING
TO APOLOGIZE FOR THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES YOU ALLOW TO BE SPREAD
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY ON
NBC.
WHAT ABOUT JEFF BEZOS, YOU GOING
TO COME CLEAN OVER THE FRONT
PAGE DECEPTION EVERY DAY IN THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
WILL YOU AT LEAST STOP REFERRING
TO FAR LEFT COLLUSION OBSESSED
HACK JENNIFER RUBEN AND OTHERS
AS CONSERVATIVES?
THEY'RE NOT.
IS THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
EXECUTIVE EDITOR, IS HE GOING TO
GIVE BACK THE PAPER'S PULITZER
PRIZE FOR COLLUSION REPORTING
GIVEN THEY WERE CAUGHT NOW
REPORTING A HOAX.
THEY ALL LIED TO WE THE PEOPLE
DAY AFTER DAY FOR TWO PLUS
YEARS.
IN REALITY, WE KNOW THERE WILL
NEVER BE A MEA CULPA FROM ANY OF
THESE FAKE NEWS OUTLETS.
THEY'LL NEVER APOLOGIZE.
THEY'LL NEVER RETRACT.
THEIR LIES AND ANONYMOUS
SOURCING.
JOURNALISM, I TOLD YOU IN 2007,
IT'S DEAD, IT'S BURIED.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT I SAID
LIGHTLY.
THEY HAVE EARNED THEIR HORRIBLE
REPUTATIONS.
NEVER VETTED OBAMA.
THEY RUSHED TO JUDGMENT GOING
BACK TO RICHARD JEWEL.
LOOK WHAT THEY DID TO A
16-YEAR-OLD KID AND OTHER
16-YEAR-OLDS FROM COVINGTON,
NICHOLAS SANDMAN AND THE
COVINGTON KIDS.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID IN THE
SMOLLETT CASE.
LOOK WHAT THEY DID TO THE
CAMBRIDGE POLICE, DARREN WILSON,
MICHAEL BROWN IN FERGUSON.
THEY RUSHED TO JUDGMENT IN
BALTIMORE.
THE FAKE RAPE ALLEGATIONS AT
UVA.
THE FAKE RAPE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST THE DUKE LACROSSE TEAM.
DUE PROCESS BE DAMNED.
EQUAL JUSTICE BE DAMNED UNDER
THE LAW.
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS BE
DAMNED.
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES, TO ALL OF THEM BE
DAMNED.
THE MEDIA MOB, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY MOB, THEY HAVE CAUSED
GREAT HARM AND DIVISION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY LAUGHED AT THE IDEA THAT
DONALD TRUMP COULD WIN.
THEY BEGGED HIM TO RUN.
BY THE WAY, ON ALL THOSE CASES
WE MENTIONED, WE DIDN'T RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH ANOTHER CASE.
WE ALLOWED DUE PROCESS.
WE ALLOWED THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, BUT IT'S NEVER BEEN
THIS BIG.
NOW THAT HE'S PRESIDENT, THEY
HAVE NEVER TAKEN THE TIME TO
EVER COVER DONALD TRUMP'S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHICH HAVE BEEN
RECORD-BREAKING.
THEY HIT HIM.
THEY HATE ALL OF WE THE PEOPLE
THAT DARD T
THAT DAREDT
THAT DARED TO VOTE FOR HIM.
THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER.
WE, THE IR REDEEMABLE DEPLO
DEPLORABLES.
IT'S CAUSED THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
TO BE WRONG OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
NPR EMBARRASSED AFTER IT LIED
ABOUT DON JR.'S SENATE
TESTIMONY.
WE PAY FOR THEIR COVERAGE.
BLATANTLY WRONG ABOUT MICHAEL
COHEN'S TRIP TO PRAGUE.
THE GUARDIAN REPORTING ABOUT
MUELLER AND JULIAN ASSAUNGE.
FAKE NEWS STORY AFTER FAKE NEWS
STORY, LIE AFTER LIE, PROPAGANDA
AFTER PROPAGANDA.
IF IT HAD TO DO WITH RUSSIA,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WELL, THE STORY
WAS HASTILY PROPERTIED AND FACTS
WERE -- REPORTED AND FACTS WERE
NOTHING MORE THAN AN AFTER
THOUGHT.
LOOK AT MORE OF THE VIDEO
EVIDENCE.
>> THE SORT OF DOSSIER A OF
ALLEGED DIRT THAT THE RUSSIANS
ALLEGEDLY SAY THEY ALLEGEDLY
HAVE ON DONALD TRUMP.
ALLEGED DIRT THEY ALLEGEDLY USED
TO ALLEGEDLY CULTIVATE HIM AS
BASICALLY A RUSSIAN ASSET.
>> GET THE PERSON'S PHONE
RECORDS.
HERE THEY SEE THESE CALLS TO THE
BLOCKED NUMBER.
NOW THERE SEEMS TO BE GOOD
EVIDENCE THAT THAT WAS PROBABLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> MICHAEL COHEN CLAIMS THAT
THEN CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP KNEW
IN ADVANCE ABOUT THE JUNE 2016
MEETING IN TRUMP TOWER.
>> THESE SOURCES TELL US THAT
COHEN IS WILLING TO MAKE THAT
ASSERTION TO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER.
>> WE BEGIN WITH A NEW REPORT
THAT PAUL MANAFORT, THE
PRESIDENT'S FORMER CAMPAIGN
CHAIRMAN, PAID SECRET VISITS,
MULTIPLE ONES TO JULIAN ASSANGE
IN LONDON.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO "THE
GUARDIAN."
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DIRECTED HIS
ATTORNEY TO LIE TO CONGRESS.
>> Sean: WHY NO DUE PROCESS?
WHY NO PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE?
BLATANT FALSE REPORTING RUSHING
TO JUDGMENT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THE ANSWER'S SIMPLE.
THIS CORRUPT PARTISAN MEDIA MOB
IS A PART OF THE NEW RADICAL
EXTREME DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY.
THEY CLEARLY WORK TOGETHER.
THEY DEVELOP, THEY PUSH THE SAME
NARRATIVE USING THE SAME WORDS
WHETHER IT IS TRUE OR NOT.
OUTLETS LIKE FAKE NEWS CNN,
CONSPIRACY TV, NBC.
THEY HAVE BECOME NOTHING MORE
THAN THE PROPAGANDA ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT'S WHY WHEN THEY TRY TO KILL
US HERE AT FOX AND YOU SUPPORT
US, YOU ARE ALLOWING THE ONLY
VOICE OF REASON ON THE AIR HALF
THE TIME.
THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA
SOUNDED EXACTLY ALIKE.
REMEMBER THEIR COMMENTS ABOUT
COLLUSION?
GEE, THEY SOUND LIKE ONE
ANOTHER.
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE ONE MIND, ONE
HEART, ONE BODY, ONE SOUL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU KNOW, MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES, THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
BEEN SAYING THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION, NONE AT ALL.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO SAY THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF INCLUSION.
NO D
NO COLLUSION WHATSOEVER.
>> WE SAW STRONG EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE CHOOSING TO
BURY IT.
>> OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
YEAR, WE HAVE SEEN, I THINK, A
MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE CAMPAIGN
AND THE RUSSIANS.
>> THE EVIDENCE IS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT THERE WAS COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
RUSSIANS.
>> YOU THINK THERE'S EVIDENCE
PRETTY CLEAR?
>> THE ED IS THERE.
>> IT SEEMS QUITE CLEAR THE
PRESENT KEEPS SAYING NO
COLLUSION.
HOW HIGH DID THAT COLLUSION
WENT.
IT WAS CLEARLY A CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OF AN HONEST
ELECTION.
>> THIS LOOKS LIKE AN EXPLOSIVE
INDICTMENT, THE FACTS THEY SET
FORTH LOOK LIKE COLLUSION.
>> WE SAW COLD, HARD EVIDENCE OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THE TRUMP
FAMILY, EAGERLY INTENDING TO
COLLUDE POSSIBLY WITH RUSSIA.
>> Sean: ALL LIES.
IN THE END, WE NOW KNOW THE
TRUTH.
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION, THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY WAS NOTHING
MORE THAN A COPING MECHANISM BY
PEOPLE THAT COULDN'T HANDLE
LOSING, DESPERATELY HOPING THE
2016 ELECTION RESULTS WERE NOT
WHAT THEY WERE.
SOME EVIL FORCE WAS BEHIND THE
SCENES, BEHIND THE CURTAIN
PULLING THE STRINGS, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
NEVER BEFORE AS A COUNTRY HAVE
WE WITNESSED SUCH SORE LOSERISM
EVER LIKE THIS.
SO MANY LIES, SO MUCH HYSTERIA
AND BREATHLESS REPORTING.
AND DEMOCRATIC HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN SCHIFF -- I
CALL HIM THE COWARDLY SCHIFF,
LIED REPEATEDLY WHEN HE SAID
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
HE IS NOT TO BE TRUSTED.
SHOULD BE TAKEN OFF AS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
HE'S A NATIONAL DISGRACE.
AS IS CONGRESSWOMAN WATERS LYING
TO YOU WHEN SHE VOWED TO IMPEACH
TRUMP OVER COLLUSION.
YOU CAN NEVER TRUST PEOPLE THAT
LIE LIKE THIS OR CONGRESSMAN
ERIC SOLLWELL WHO SAID HE'D SEEN
PLENTY OF EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
HE IS A LIE I LIAR.
OR EXPLAINING THAT WE ARE
HEADING TOWARDS A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
MORE TOTAL B.S.
AND THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
AND THE HYSTERIA ON THE LEFT WAS
WIDESPREAD.
IF NOT FOR TALK RADIO -- THANK
GOD FOR RUSH, MARK, MY
COLLEAGUES HERE, MANY OF THEM AT
THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL, TUCKER,
LAURA, A FEW OTHER BRAVE,
LOGICAL INDEPENDENT THINKERS
STANDING ALONE, THERE WOULD HAVE
BEEN NO ONE OUT THERE ADVOCATING
FOR THE TRUTH, DISCOVERING THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER SCANDAL
IN OUR HISTORY.
NOBODY.
WE NOW HAVE TO CONCERN OURSELVES
AS A COUNTRY WITH A TWO-TIERED
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE FEATURING
HIGH-RANKING DEEP STATE POWERFUL
OFFICIALS.
WE EMPOWER THEM.
THAT TRY TO FIRST RIG AN
ELECTION IN FAVOR OF HILLARY
CLINTON BY EXONERATING HER FROM
WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN OBVIOUS
OBSTRUCTION AND A VIOLATION OF
THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
THEN THEY USE THEIR POWER TO TRY
AND INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION
WITH RUSSIA LIES THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR ALL OF IRONIES.
THAT'S WHY OUR HANNITY WATCH ON
THE DEEP STATE IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER.
I AM TONIGHT WEARING AN FBI FLAG
PIN GIVEN TO ME BY A RANK AND
FILE FBI INDIVIDUAL.
CAN'T NAME HIM.
HE'LL GET IN TROUBLE.
BUT LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE I KNOW
IN THE FBI, THANKING ME FOR
DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN THE 99%
OF BRAVE, DEDICATED AGENTS OF
THE PREMIERE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY OF THE WORLD THAT DO A
TREMENDOUS JOB.
THAT ARE EMBARRASSED BY WHAT
THEIR LEADERSHIP HAS DONE.
THEY SERVE OUR COUNTRY EVERY
DAY.
DON'T PUT THEM IN THE SAME
ALIGNMENT WITH THE CONTAIN,
STRZOK, AND PAGES OF THE WORLD.
THIS IS NOW TIME THAT WE GET THE
JUSTICE THAT WE DESERVE.
THIS IS NOW TIME FOR THOSE THAT
ABUSE THE POWER THAT YOU GAVE
THEM, THEIR DAY OF RECKONING
MUST NOW COME OR ELSE THIS WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN.
MY SOURCES ARE TELLING ME IT'S
ALL ABOUT TO COME CASCADING
DOWN.
THIS ALL STARTED WHEN THEY
RIGGED THE INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY'S E-MAIL SCANDAL.
THERE WAS CLEAR, COMPELLING AND
CON TRO
CONTROVERITABLE EVIDENCE THAT
SHE MISHANDLED CONFIDENTIAL
EVIDENCE ON A PRIVATE SERVER.
NO ATTORNEY COULD GET ME OR ANY
OF YOU OUT OF SUBPOENA E-MAILS
THAT YOU MAY DESTROY, 33,000 OF
THEM, AND THEN YOU ACID WASH
YOUR HARD DRIVE WITH BLEACH AND
YOU BANG UP YOUR PHONES AND
DEVICES WITH HAMMERS AND REMOVE
THE SIM CARDS.
REMEMBER STRZOK AND PAGE AND
THEIR TEXT?
REMEMBER ABOUT TRUMP SUPPORTERS
THEY SAID WERE SMELLY WALMART
PEOPLE AND HILLARY SHOULD WIN
100 MILLION TO ZERO.
STRZOK WHO DID THE INTERVIEW
WITH FLYNN AND CLINTON.
IN THE CLINTON CAGE, IMAGINE
ALLOWING TWO OF HER FRIENDS IN
THE ROOM WHILE SHE'S BEING
INTERROGATED IN AN
INVESTIGATION.
OR AS LORETTA LYNCH SAID, A
MATTER.
HE WAS WRITING HILLARY'S
EXONERATION WITH COMEY'S
BLESSING IN MAY OF 2016.
THEY HAD NEVER DONE AN
INVESTIGATION.
THE EXONERATION BEFORE THE
INTERVIEWED HER JULY 2nd.
COMEY KPAN RAT
COMEY EXAN RAT
COMEY EXON RAT
COMEY EXONERATED HER JULY 5th.
NOT BEFORE THE INFAMOUS TARMAC
MEETING BETWEEN BILL CLINTON AND
THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL LYNCH AND
OF COURSE THE TESTIMONY LAST
WEEK THAT LORETTA LYNCH HERSELF
WAS UP TO HER EYEBALLS IN EVERY
DECISION THAT WAS MADE.
EVEN LISA PAGE ADMITTED, THEY'RE
ALL DEMOCRATS, WE KNEW THE FIX
WAS IN.
THAT HORRIBLY FLAWED
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON NOW MUST BE REOPENED IF
WE ARE TO EVER HAVE JUSTICE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
ONCE CLINTON LOST THE ELECTION,
THE NEXT PHASE OF THE DEEP STATE
CORRUPTION, THAT KICKED IN.
THE INSURANCE POLICY, HILLARY'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
LIES.
IMAGINE RUSSIAN LIES PUT
TOGETHER BY A FOREIGN SPY.
AND THEN USED ON AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN TO GET ENTRY INTO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN THE LEAD-UP TO
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THEY DENIED CARTER PAGE DUE
PROCESS.
THEY DENIED CARTER PAGE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
THEY REPEATEDLY COMMITTED FRAUD
AGAINST FISA COURT JUDGES, THEY
DID IT BY OMISSION, AND OF
COURSE THEY USED WHAT IS
UNVERIFIED, UNCORROBORATED
INFORMATION.
REMEMBER, CHRISTOPHER STEELE
DOESN'T STAND BY IT TO THIS DAY.
BRUCE ORR WARNED EVERYBODY, THIS
WAS IN OCTOBER 2016, THAT
DOSSIER WAS TAINTED.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
CHRIS FEAR STEELE HATED TRUMP
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE TESTIFIED
I'M ONLY 50/50 SAYING IT'S
INTELLIGENCE AS TO WHETHER ANY
OF THE DOSSIER WAS TRUE.
MOST OF IT NOW WAS DEBUNKED.
THAT RENDERED THAT DOSSIER
UNVERIFIABLE.
THEY SAY THEY TRIED TO VERIFY
IT.
THEY'RE LYING.
THAT DIDN'T STOP THE DOSSIER
FROM THEN BEING USED AS KNE
FROM THEN BEING USED AS NUE
FROM THEN BEING USED AS NUNES
AND GRASSLEY SAID.
TONIGHT IT'S TIME FOR
TRANSPARENCY.
TONIGHT, WE BEGIN A PROCESS THAT
WILL TAKE US A LONG TIME OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT IS NOW TIME TO DECLASSIFY ALL
OF THOSE FISA APPLICATIONS.
YOU TALK ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THOSE FISA
WARRANTS WERE BASED ON HILLARY'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
LIES.
AND THEN FULLY EXPOSE EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE DEEP STATE
ACTORS WHO ABUSE THE POWER THAT
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GAVE
THEM.
JAMES COMEY, LET'S START WITH
HIM.
LET'S START WITH SALLY YATES.
THEY NEED TO BE INVESTIGATED.
McCABE NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
ALL WHO SIGNED OFF ON THE FISA
WARRANTS NEED TO BE FULLY
INVESTIGATED.
SUSAN RICE, CLAPPER, LYNCH, AND
ALSO IF LYNCH IS RUNNING THIS
WHOLE FIX, WHAT DID OBAMA KNOW
AND WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
THEY ALL MUST BE NOW PUT UNDER
OATH, INVESTIGATED BECAUSE THEY
WEAPONIZED THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE AND RESOURCES AND
THEY LITERALLY BROKE THE LAW.
THEY SURVEILLED AGAINST THE LAW,
THEY UNMASKED AMERICANS AGAINST
THE LAW, THEY LEAKED RAW
INTELLIGENCE AGAINST THE LAW,
AND THEY TRIED TO FAVOR ON
ELECTION IN ONE SIDE AND NOT THE
OTHER.
AND THEN BLUDGEON AND UNDO AN
ELECTION.
BY THE WAY, COMEY, OH, HE
BELIEVED IN THE DOSSIER IN
OCTOBER OF 2016, BUT TOLD TRUMP
IN JANUARY OF '17, IT'S
SALACIOUS, IT'S NOT VERIFIED.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRIVATE MEMOS HE
PURPOSEFULLY LEAKED, GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS TO A SPECIAL COUNSEL
TO BEGIN THE INVESTIGATION.
THINK ABOUT THE HARM THAT ALL OF
THIS HAS DONE.
IMAGINE WHAT PRESIDENT COULD
WITHSTAND THIS, DENIGHING A
FREE, FAIR, OPEN ELECTION AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THEIR RIGHT
TO PICK THEIR PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS.
AND ATTEMPTED FRANKLY COUP OF A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
APPOINTING A SPECIAL COUNSEL
FILLED WITH PARTISAN DEMOCRATS.
PEOPLE THAT WENT TO HILLARY'S
VICTORY PARTY AND EVEN
REPRESENTED AS ATTORNEYS HILLARY
CLINTON.
THIS HAS CAUSED ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF COLLATERAL DAMAGE TO MANY
PEOPLE WHO CANNOT AFFORD THE
LAWYERS THEY HAD TO HIRE.
THE PRESEN
THE PRESIDENT, HIS WIFE, HIS
KIDS, HIS FAMILY, HIS ADVISORS.
MICHAEL FLYNN, CARTER PAGE,
GEORGE POP DA
GEORGE PAP DA
GEORGE PAPADA
GEORGE PAPADOPOULO
GEORGE PAP DO
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS AND SO MANY
OTHERS.
I WARNED DIRECTOR COMEY A LONG